[Music]
ladies and gentlemen what you have
witnessed here today is a flash mob of
flashing flashes flashing truly the
comedic stylings of this show have hit a
new low
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film Theory the smartest but
definitely not the fastest of shows on
YouTube unless you measure speed by the
time it takes to make you cringe in
which case call me Usain Bolt hey you
remember last year when Justice League
came out no no what well not all that
surprising since this thing earned less
than Man of Steel which means that most
you watching probably didn't go out see
it but don't worry you didn't miss all
that much here I'm gonna catch you up on
the best bits by the way spoiler alert
yeah basically the flash told a whole
movie Aquaman wine Wonder Woman was the
victim of oddly sexist jokes and Batman
just refused to act ever hear of
Superman he died fighting next to me oh
yeah I guess cyborg was there too but
even in writing that recap I completely
forgot that he was even a part of the
team so you know nope the flash was the
only useful one my special skills
include viola a web design fluent in
sign language that only was he a well
realized character but he was also the
only character to demonstrate truly
useful powers in the movies big place
seeds the situation is so bad that
Batman overwhelmed by dealing outclass
by the actual superheroes with actual
superpowers attempts to commit suicide
as a part of the final battle
I'm not even exaggerating when I say
that everyone else has to be like no
Batman you are useful to this team you
you you're great you you add so much of
so much leadership to the team even
though your decision to revive Superman
almost gets us all killed
oh yeah Superman gets himself for a born
and record time it way through the movie
which is treated as this big reveal
Supt you know you can't reveal stuff
that's already on the boxart
he even gets himself some really neat
cgi lips in the process and the zombie
soup's turns on the crew because you
know DC wanted another crack at the
whole superhero V superhero concept
because it went so well last time and
then he flies off to a cornfield assault
because the movie needed a reason to
ensure that the grossly overpowered
character didn't save the day until the
final battle best word of the ending
Steppenwolf is seated Batman chooses the
Justice League HQ there's a Deathstroke
Easter Egg Superman destroys all life on
the planet Earth and end credits like I
said you didn't miss all that much oh
I'm sorry
were you wondering about that whole
Superman destroying all life on the
planet Earth bit yeah well you don't
actually see it happen on screen but it
is definitely an unintended consequence
of Superman's actions throughout this
movie based on what we see during the
Easter Egg ending of Justice League I
can prove for a scientific fact that
Superman would decimate the earth that
he had sworn died and was reborn to
protect to understand how that works
though our story begins with the flash
so Barry Allen was a scientist who one
night gets struck by lightning next
thing you know he can move at incredible
speeds as you do that freak accident
gives Barry the ability to tap into
what's known as the Speed Force an extra
dimensional source of energy that allows
him to not only move fast but
fundamentally alter the way physics
works around his body
in short the Speed Force allows Barry to
move at light speed Ludacris feat
Ludacris speeds pitch honestly is
probably a more accurate descriptor
without having to worry about all the
messy consequences that physics demands
would come with moving quickly and let
me assure you those consequences are
definitely messy you see when you swim
the water in front of you has to move
out of your way but this is true for any
fluid that you're moving through water
certainly but it can also be things like
pudding if you pull it lava juice and
fill your bathtub with random liquids
for those sweet sweet cute
it's views but more than anything else
the fluid we deal with day to day is air
when we normally run through air we pass
through the air molecules pretty darn
easily because their velocity is so much
higher than our own the molecules just
move out of the way but when you start
running at ludicrous speeds the
particles are forced together they get
trapped in front of you becoming in
essence a molecular traffic jam because
they can't get out of the way of each
other and as you can imagine not only as
weird stuff happening in front of you
but you're also leaving a path of chaos
in your wake as well as the flash builds
up these molecules in front of them he's
creating a mini vacuum behind themselves
a low density area left in his weight
and as a result air molecules rush in to
fill that space like the Red Sea Post
Noah what is this collection of air
molecules really that big of a deal well
just how much damage all this would
cause would depend on the Flash's speed
now in the comics the flash has been
shown to travel any speed he needs to
and he's been able to reach those
ludicrous speeds I keep mentioning as
just one example in JLA number 48 a
series covering The Adventures of the
Justice League a nuclear warhead is
launched towards North Korea threatening
to kill over half a million people to
save all those lives the flash Wally
West at this point rushes in and rescues
each and every one of those five hundred
thousand people carrying them all 35
miles away but here's the catch he
rescues them after of the bomb has
already detonated so he's rescuing
500,000 people in what the comic says is
point zero zero zero zero one
microseconds that means he ran 35 miles
there and 35 miles back at least 250,000
times since he could be carrying two
people at a time in point zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero one second doing the math that
translates to him moving nine trillion
times the speed of light but since
that's an absurd number and since I'm
specifically interested in Justice
League let's just stick to how the flash
behaves in the DC EU if I'm being
thorough and I kind of gotta be for
anything involving comics other as I get
inundated with really angry emails I
should technically mention that we've
seen the flash move faster than the
speed of light back in Batman V Superman
flash appeared to Bruce Wayne telling
him to look into Lois well some people
have written this off as just a part of
Batman's nightmare that would actually
make no sense at this point in the movie
Bruce has no idea that Superman is Clark
Kent has never seen the flash before and
would only have known Lois Lane as a
reporter so this is the flash reaching
out to Bruce by running faster than time
itself but since that's just a theory I
have let's look for something a bit more
concrete
luckily Justice League gives me exactly
what I need while flash is trying to
outmaneuver a newly resurrected Superman
a dramatic moment reveals that Superman
is keeping his gaze locked on the flash
as he moves this tells us one very
important detail that the flash is not
moving faster than the speed of light in
this scene in fact at this moment flash
is moving slow enough that Superman from
a few feet away mind you can keep a
visual lock on him you see sight works
when I takes in light that's been
reflected off of another object as a
result what you're seeing is always
slightly behind what's actually there as
it takes time for the light to travel
between the object in your eye and then
for your brain to process that image so
if you were to move faster than the
speed of light well weird things would
happen because relativity as we know it
would start to break down but one thing
other people certainly wouldn't be able
to do is accurately track your movements
Superman may be super but even he can't
speed up the rate at which light is
traveling and also yeah he may be
tracking flash using some other method
but it seems like it's clearly meant to
be that Superman sees the flash so even
though it's very possible that Barry
Allen is able to travel faster than the
speed of light it's very possible that
Superman is tracking the Flash's
movements using some other method for
our purposes today let's just assume
that Barry is traveling slightly
lower than the speed of light allowing
Superman to see him in the scene don't
worry it doesn't change the end results
all that much the speed of light is 671
million miles per hour so let's put
Barry slightly below that at 670 million
miles per hour here's the problem at
speeds that high Barry would be walking
around with a fusion bomb going off on
his chest no joke humans right now have
a hard time achieving fusion because of
a little wrinkle called the Coulomb
barrier for fusion to happen particles
have to get really really close together
about 10 to the negative 15th meters
close in order for the strong nuclear
force that exists in atoms to fuse the
particles together however there's a
problem with that
just like magnets to protons that are
pushed together repel each other due to
their mutual positive charge this is the
Coulomb barrier now the barrier can be
overcome by traveling really really
really fast speeds that under most
normal circumstances are nearly
impossible for humans to achieve I'm
talking 44 million seven hundred
thirty-eight thousand seven hundred
twenty-five miles per hour and levels of
fast but superheroes don't operate under
normal circumstances like I said Barry
is traveling at 670 million miles per
hour on a conservative estimate
that's nearly 15 times faster than
what's needed to overcome Coulomb's
barrier and so fusion reactions would be
happening over and over again in that
dense cloud of molecules that's building
up in front of him and each of those
reactions would correspond to a
temperature of around 5 billion degrees
and that's not all according to work
done at the University of California San
Diego these sorts of temperatures and
energies would turn little bits of air
molecules into plasma left alone those
small particles of plasma would explode
to the size of football fields in
pointone milliseconds so as he ran Barry
would be lighting off thousands of
high-energy fusion reactions and giant
plasma explosions wherever he went close
to light speed which is why in justice
league and the comics it's so lucky that
he has
access to the speedforce which renders
all of this a moot point
remember the speedforce warps the
physics of the air around him so he
doesn't overheat and cause a plasma
streak and that would be the end except
for one man super man at the end of the
movie flash and suits go in for a race
Superman stop you're gonna kill us all
you see despite his ability to move
incredibly fast Superman doesn't have
access to the Speed Force he's not what
the DC Universe refers to as a speedster
Superman travels fast because of his
strength and his muscles not because he
has access to some extra dimensional
power jerk in the movies and comics
Superman has moved fast often multiple
times faster than speed alight but he
has never once in all the research that
I did tapped into that special force and
that becomes a serious problem because
Superman is about to race Barry Allen
around the world and at least try to
keep up and thanks to this moment from
Man of Steel we know based on the fire
surrounding his body that Superman
actively collides with the atmosphere
and burns on re-entry at really fast
speeds
unlike Barry though there is no magical
field extending a millimeter away from a
skin that can magic away this problem
with no Speed Force to control the air
molecules around him all those awful
things I said about Barry
absolutely apply to Superman he's gonna
ignite the air wherever he goes and in a
race of this magnitude that definitely
means fusion level reactions and plasma
eruptions across the globe happening in
less than a blink of an eye when
Superman reaches even half of light
speed he's already generating an
incredible 9.8 times 10 to the ninth
power joules of energy that is roughly
40 times more powerful than the
strongest hydrogen bomb ever detonated
that is going to devastate the planet
below him wherever he goes
completing the job that Zod and
Steppenwolf couldn't do on their own
Earth's greatest threat was its greatest
hero all along this Batman V Superman
was right he has the power to wipe out
the entire human race and if we believe
there's even a 1% chance that he is our
enemy we have to take it as an absolute
certainty oh you just feel dirty even
saying that but hey that's just a theory
a film theory
and before we end today's episode a
special announcement Cirrus merch is on
sale now but supplies are super limited
so if you want to look cool and nerdy
and Rock some bright green socks well
then click the link in the description
below or the iCard in the upper right
hand corner of the screen we've already
run out of three items so make sure
you're clicking that link now to grab
your t-shirt before they're gone forever
and as a special bonus to anyone who
places an order you get a complimentary
limited edition game theory pin and and
in true Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory spirit a chance at winning a
golden coin not just any golden coin a
gold coin that might get you access to
something pretty darn special later this
year if you're a fan of any of the
theorists channels I guarantee it's
something that you're gonna be wanting
in your possession now put that away
Stephanie you're looking too much like
the girl from get outs and why aren't
you putting the milk in the cereal
that's just just weird that you're
eating them separate so anyway click the
link in the description or the I icon in
the upper right hand corner of the
screen grab your merch before it
disappears and make sure you're showing
off your nerdy theorists bright lime
green pride now if you'll excuse me I
need to do some research on my summer
vacation I'll see you next week